with levon adonyan here after a great
win against maxine vasherla graph you
went into the lions then you came with
preparation you took the night off and
you found this move rook hf1 tell us a
little bit about the inspiration of this
i didn't really find it uh
when i was struggling with
some
health issues in india uh it was that
they were preparing fabi
uh for niger i think it was against
masudu
and uh
robert has came up with this idea to
play rook f1 here right master robert
has the coach of the u.s olympics team
in india and then
we analyzed it a bit
and
we gave uh
fabi a green light and well
it didn't happen on his board but uh
i think we both were
looking for an opportunity to play this
very interesting idea and tell us a
little bit what is the point of putting
the rook on f1 rather than the normal
rook he one
yeah quite often you get this i mean
when black for example makes a long
castle here
quite often you have to play like c4
let's say knight f4
bishop e6 oh bishop of 6
bishop 6 bishop b4
knight e6
knight a5 knight c5
and if the rook only won if the rook is
standing on e1 then we don't have those
options to play b4 here because b4 ft at
some point but here the rook is hitting
the bishop and then queen to d5
and also just in case rook on f1 i mean
we're kind of stopping some uh
ideas because we want to play f4 at all
times right so it's i won't say it's uh
granting quite any advantage but it's a
new try and
i thought why not now angels were saying
that knight h7 was the best move in this
position and after a very long thing
maxine found it were you surprised that
he played what seems like a bit of an
inhuman move
no i'm not surprised because he's a very
strong player but i think at one moment
he of course found this best idea at one
moment he just got careless on move
number 19. of course rook h7 has to move
we were wondering what is the difference
uh with rook h7 he manages to put the
king on uh f8
faster and there is never
like danger for him
starting from the you know queen h6
check right yes
he always gets it
yeah because the rook is just defending
yeah yeah so it's just safer for his
king and also
rook can be surprisingly effective
at protecting the f7 pawn
in different lines so this was the way
to equalize but you knew about rook ga
tell us a little bit about where your
knowledge ended
i knew that rook g8 is not the right
move and here i just thought and i
thought well knight a5 looks quite
logical right 95 in this position
play continued king f8 bishop b4 king g7
and after queen takes d6 did you feel
you were in control yeah this looks like
a very nice position but uh i think
later on i started playing
sub-optimal moves i think i gave him
some chances maybe i should have just
grabbed the
bloody pawn on if i
actually we loved your move rookie four
objectively according to my engine it
evaluated both as about the same amount
of advantage and we thought that from a
practical perspective considering his
time situation rookie 4 was just a
better move
that's that's what i thought as well but
then somehow he got this counter play i
mean his maximum is so resourceful with
this h4 bishop g5 i think already here i
i was feeling that my advantage is
slowly disappearing yes
yeah and then i thought okay a4 well
with a4 of course i allow rook takes c4
which i thought is very close to the
drone this one rope takes immediately
contacts rook takes a5 and rook b4 check
you can't go to the a file because you
picked that up yeah and king c2 or k4
still
this is hanging this is hanging yeah i
was thinking that this is this is
already a bit uh
out of my control i was thinking that
maybe
i have some rook b7 here but this is
way too dublin yeah because rookie to
check here is also kind of unpleasant
knight king b3 rk5
ah then you just trade the rook yeah
so i have to play some king c3 and
i don't know if
i have any winning chances here after
some e4 or something like that right it
gets it gets messy he didn't find that
he actually went for this variation with
a5 e4 rook 7 d4 this we love this move
thought it was very clever during the
time control yeah it was the only chance
to win the game i felt because otherwise
it just has too much counter play and
that's the thing he kind of from
distance he thought he has this rook b7
and rugby five but then rookie four is
there and he cannot recapture the pawn
because rugby three king city before
king c3 let me put that on the board
rugby sound or rp5 it doesn't matter
doesn't matter take check rook here and
you're attacking both the rook and the
bishop and i'm assuming on rook before
you have king c3 right yes you attack
the rook and again the bishop on f4 so
that's enough time to do that and he
blitzed out f5 with seconds also bad
move i think rookie 7 is is
should be a draw yeah rookie 7 is what
we the engines were suggesting as well
as we do have a finally a result in this
game we have been expecting it for
upwards of three hours by this point
nepo has drawn against favi so going
back into this analysis rookie 7 did
seem to be good but you got to this
position out of time control did you
feel that you were already winning in
this end game yeah i felt king h5 was a
losing move i felt that his only chance
was bishop g5 but then i felt i have
this clever rook takes a f5 rook at 59
d6
and you know
my knight is very useful because i have
this knight f7 check
when he takes the pawn or a knight d4
when he goes rook of two
yeah
yeah
levon it seems that you put a lot of
pressure on your opponent on the board
but i've noticed on your style that
you're also playing very quickly almost
reminding me of how nepo wins a lot of
his games is this on purpose
yeah i'm trying to learn from
my
colleagues and uh
also
uh well i haven't won a
classical game for so long that i think
i'm losing patience
well this one was definitely a beautiful
one with the ideas in the in the opening
in the middle game and in the endgame
winning all around thank you everyone
for joining us and good luck
uh lavon quick question
annie help you with uh choosing the
shirt
absolutely absolutely you like it i love
it i love it
if you can get an extra large for me you
know because of my swollen pectorals
that would be great
absolutely
thank you lavon this just feels a nice
draw by the way i love that bishop f3
that really put a nice finishing